se faire opérer les yeux au laser ça
fait à la fois un peu rêver et un peu
flipper d'un côté ça a l'air magique
comme truc mais d'un autre du laser dans
les yeux ça fait pareil
c'est
ultra impressionnant d'ailleurs
normalement quand on serre dans laser on
doit mettre des lunettes de protection
quand même donc et puis surtout bah on
sait pas trop comment ça marche
si moi je sais
allez d'accord je vais me changer je
reviens je vous raconte ça
[Musique]
avant de commencer laissez-moi juste
vous dire un petit mot cette vidéo est
sponsorisée par nextory nextory c'est
l'un des premiers services de livres
audio et d'ebooks en Europe donc vous
pouvez choisir de lire avec vos yeux ou
avec vos oreilles ce qui peut être
pratique si vous vous êtes fait opérer
des yeux au laser par exemple et puis si
vous n'êtes pas fait opérer des yeux
c'est cool aussi parce qu'ils ont plein
de formats différents des livres donc
audio ou ebooks y compris des BD mais
aussi des podcasts des séries audio des
journaux des magazines etc il y a plus
de 250 000 titres dans tous les styles
donc vous allez trouver votre bonheur si
vous aimez la SF il y en a si vous aimez
la littérature classique il y en a si
vous aimez le corps humain il y en a si
vous êtes un enfant que vous possédez un
smartphone du pouvoir d'achat pour vous
offrir un des trois abonnements et que
vous aimez les livres pour enfants il y
en a si vous avez faim que vous cherchez
un livre de recettes il y en a si vous
voilà donc il suffit de s'abonner de
télécharger l'appli et de faire fouiller
regardez ça vous voyez un peu comme j'ai
farfouille et évidemment comme je suis
super sympa j'ai un petit cadeau pour
vous allez sur ma page perso le lien est
là et dans la description de la vidéo
cliquez dessus et vous verrez mes
petites reco perso plus un bouton sur
lequel il vous suffit de cliquer pour
avoir 45 jours offerts sur nextory donc
bah foncez mais revenons-en à nos
feuilletons si vous voulez savoir
pourquoi j'ai ce visage atroce dans la
séquence précédente restez bien jusqu'à
la fin de cette vidéo
pendant longtemps quand on allait des
problèmes de vue on avait pas trop le
choix on mettait des lunettes et puis
voilà et encore ça c'est à partir du
moment où les lunettes ont été inventées
avant on faisait avec et puis à la fin
du 19e siècle on a inventé ce qui allait
devenir les lentilles de contact c'était
un petit peu mieux à chaque fois ça a
été des inventions qui ont changé la vie
des gens mais ça reste quand même des
appareils extérieurs un petit peu
contraignants on n'est pas guéris et ce
n'est qu'au 20e siècle qu'on a développé
des techniques de chirurgie efficaces
pour corriger les troubles de la vue et
c'est pas si étonnant qu'il ait fallu
attendre longtemps comme ça parce que
l’œil c'est quand même une petite bête
fragile dans les années 30 il y a un
chirurgien japonais qui s'appelle
sankishi Sato qui a fait ce qu'on
estimait être les premières tentatives
d'opération chirurgicale pour corriger
les troubles de la vue alors je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails techniques
parce que c'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui
mais on peut résumer ça en disant que ça
vaguement été une boucherie et que la
technique a été abandonnée abandonnée
jusqu'à ce que viatoslav fiorov qui a un
ophtalmo russe se reproche dessus au
début des années 70 pour tenter
d'améliorer la technique mais entre
temps il y avait un ophtalmo colombien
cette fois qui s'appelle José baracker
qui avait développé une technique qui
sert encore de base aux opérations
telles qu'on les pratiques aujourd'hui
ces chirurgiens et quelques autres c'est
les pionniers de la chirurgie réfractive
et ça ça nécessite quelques explications
ne serait-ce que pour comprendre ce que
ça veut dire chirurgie réfractive la
chirurgie réfractive c'est des
opérations qui consistent à corriger la
réfraction de nos yeux et là vous êtes
bien avancé bon ok on va commencer par
la base comment ça marche nos yeux
comment on voit et ben nos yeux c'est un
petit peu comme des appareils photos il
capte de la lumière et il les transforme
en images voilà comment ça se passe les
rayons lumineux qui sont renvoyés par
les objets qu'on regarde il traverse
d'abord la cornée qui est la première
membrane transparente de l'oeil mais
vous allez voir comment en parler
ensuite il rentre dans l'oeil par la
pupille le petit trou noir qu'on a là au
milieu ensuite il passe à travers le
cristallin qui est une espèce de
lentille transparente juste derrière et
qui est chargé de faire la mise au point
et puis la lumière elle est projetée
finalement contre la rétine qu'elle a
tout au fond de nos yeux ensuite ces
informations lumineuses elles sont
transformées en impulsion électrique qui
sont envoyés au cerveau qui se charge
d'analyser tout ça et de nous dire alors
là ce que tu es en train de regarder
c'est un poney ou un lampadaire ou Kev
Adams
et ben voilà la réfraction c'est ça
c'est la façon dont les rayons lumineux
sont déviés à travers l'oeil pour aller
converger sur la rétine et quand ils
sont pas des pieds correctement et ben
on voit pas clair ça s'appelle une
anomalie de la réfraction il y en a 4
types différents que vous connaissez
déjà je vais vous leur donner quand même
la myopie d'abord dans ces cas-là l’œil
il est trop long et la cornée elle est
souvent trop bombée du coup quand on
regarde un objet les rayons ils
convergent pas sur la rétine il
convergent dans notre œil et dans ces
cas-là c'est la vision de loin qui est
atteinte l'hypermétropie ensuite ce
coup-là l'oeil il est trop court et
l'accordé elle peut être trop plate donc
les rayons lumineux ils convergent
derrière la rétine et c'est la vision de
près qui est atteinte avec des
phénomènes de fatigue visuelle assez
important il y a aussi la stigmatisme là
cette fois c'est la cornée qui est
irrégulière du coup les rayons ils se
focalisent à différents endroits mais
toujours pas sur la rétine et on voit
pas bien à la fois de près et de loin et
puis il y a presbytie et la ce coup-là
c'est le cristallin qui devient de moins
en moins élastique avec l'âge et du coup
il arrive plus à faire correctement son
travail d'autofocus les rayons y
convergent derrière la rétine donc on
voit mal de près dans tous les cas le
résultat c'est qu'on voit flou ou qu'on
voit un peu déformé et la chirurgie pour
corriger ses anomalies de réfraction
c'est la fameuse chirurgie réfractive
voilà bon mais alors comment ça marche
ce truc bah on a vu qu'il y avait eu
plusieurs tentatives pour essayer
d'arranger ça mais ce qui a révolutionné
toutes ces techniques c'est le laser
vous vous souvenez de José baracker
l'ophtalmo colombien dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure
c'est le moment de vous reparler un
petit peu de la technique qu'il a mis au
point pour corriger les anomalies de
réfraction je sais baraker il a eu une
idée celle de découper la cornée de ses
patients de la congeler de la sculpter
pour modifier les anomalies et puis de
la remettre dans l'oeil du patient alors
ça marchait bien mais vous vous rendez
bien compte que c'était très délicat à
réaliser c'était douloureux vous
imaginez bien et puis il y avait des
risques juste comme ça je vous montre
l'instrument qu'il a inventé pour
découper la cornée ça s'appelle un micro
keratome un petit rabot
donc voilà mais ça marche bien mais donc
ce qui a révolutionné ce type
d'opération c'est l'utilisation du laser
dans les années 70 on met au point un
type de laser qui a la particularité
d'être très précis et de ne pas risquer
d'abîmer les yeux du fait de ses
caractéristiques le laser xymère dès les
années 80 il y a des ophtalmo qui
commence à l'utiliser pour sculpter la
cornée
exactement comme faisait José baracker
mais on va se concentrer sur les deux
principales techniques qui sont
utilisées aujourd'hui la première elle
s'appelle la PKR la photo qui ratectomie
réfractive alors oui ça sonne comme un
truc hyper compliqué mais en vérité vous
allez voir que c'est plutôt simple voilà
comment ça se passe on commence par
retirer la couche superficielle de la
cornée qui s'appelle l'épithélium et de
toute façon il s'en va et il se régénère
en permanence et puis avec le laser on
va remodeler la couche principale qui
est juste en dessous et qui s'appelle le
stroma
ça permet de modifier la courbure de la
cornée donc de la rendre plus bombée si
elle est trop plate ou inversement et du
coup de faire en sorte que les rayons
convergent au bon endroit c'est-à-dire
sur la rétine et donc que les patients
voient des images nettes le laser
x-cimer il va juste retirer une très
fine couche de cornée on parle de
quelques micros et il fait ça en
quelques secondes donc l'opération elle
est très rapide faut quand même le temps
de l'installation etc mais on parle de
moins d'une demi-heure alors attention
chirurgien il vous la dirigent pas les
yeux comme ça à main levée au doigt
mouillé évidemment la machine elle est
réglée en fonction des corrections qu'on
doit apporter précisément à votre cornée
et cette machine elle utilise ce qu'on
appelle un high tracker c'est une
technologie qui suit le mouvement de vos
yeux pour que le laser soit toujours
envoyé au bon endroit l'avantage du
laser ça fait pas mal enfin sur le
moment donc l'opération elle se fait
juste avec quelques gouttes anesthésiant
dans les yeux inconvénient du coup bah
vous êtes réveillé donc ça peut ne pas
être très confortable d'abord parce
qu'on va utiliser un blépharostar
si vous avez vu Orange Mécanique vous
savez exactement comment ça marche et si
vous n'avez pas vu Orange Mécanique bah
je vais vous montrer mais que ce qu'on
peut ferme les yeux et attendre que j'ai
compté jusqu'à trois avant de les
rouvrir c'est bon allez on y va 1 2
3 c'est bon vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux
et estimez-vous heureux parce qu'avec le
blépharosta vous n'auriez pas pu faire
ça l'autre raison pour laquelle
l'opération peut être désagréable c'est
que pendant un court instant alors cours
mais quand même et ben on voit plus rien
c'est normal ça dure pas longtemps mais
quand même ça peut être un peu
angoissant quoi cette impression de
perdre la vue donc le chirurgien va vous
proposer de prendre un petit truc avant
pour vous détendre donc politique c'est
pas obligé mais si vous pensez que
potentiellement vous risquez de mal
vivre ce qui va se passer n'hésitez pas
on en a déjà parlé il y a aucune gloire
à souffrir pour rien et ben là c'est
pareil il y a aucune gloire à flipper
pour rien après l'opération on vous met
des lentilles de protection que vous
gardez cinq jours le temps que
l'épithélium repousse et puis voilà et
puis on va parler de l'autre technique
qui s'appelle le LASIK là on n'utilise
pas un mais deux lasers un premier laser
qui s'appelle un laser femtose et qui a
la particularité de faire des découpes
extrêmement précises on s'en sert pour
découper une espèce de petit capot dans
les premières couches de la cornée qu'on
rabat ensuite sur de l'autre côté c'est
littéralement un micro keratome laser
vous rappelez le petit rabot un rabot
laser ça permet de pas avoir à retirer
complètement l'épithélium comme dans la
première opération et vous allez voir
que ça aura des conséquences après
l'opération et puis on utilise aussi un
autre laser pour reculer la cornée là
c'est le même que dans l'opération
précédente c'est l'ex-maire donc en gros
l'opération elle se passe à peu près de
la même façon sauf que là il faut
d'abord découper un petit capot le
soulever puis le remettre en place à la
fin mais comme il se recolle tout seul
ce petit capot bah il y a rien à faire
de plus donc aujourd'hui c'est encore
ces deux techniques qui sont pratiquées
il y en a une troisième qui est encore
plus récente qui s'appelle smile mais je
vais pas vous embrouiller avec ça
retenez que en gros c'est à peu près
comme le LASIK sauf que là au lieu de
faire un capot complet on fait juste une
petite incision au laser dans la cornée
mais alors c'est quoi la différence
entre les deux techniques et bah la
première la PKR elle est un petit peu
moins chère écoute à peu près 2000 euros
en moyenne pour les deux yeux contre
3000 euros à peu près pour les deux yeux
avec le LASIK par contre avec avec la
PKR là qu'on va l'essence elle est plus
douloureuse et la récupération visuelle
elle est un petit peu plus lente qu'avec
le LASIK avec la PKR ça peut faire mal
pendant 5-6 jours et pareil pour
récupérer une vision convenable avec le
Lassic a priori il y a juste une gêne et
un voile visuel pendant quelques heures
après l'opération mais dès le lendemain
on y voit déjà beaucoup plus clair et au
bout de deux jours on peut reprendre le
boulot dans les deux cas les résultats
ils sont définitifs sauf bien sûr si
vous avez un trouble de la vision qui
est pas stable et qui continue à évoluer
c'est à dire si votre vue continue à se
dégrader c'est souvent le cas avec la
presbytie par exemple mais vous allez
voir on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
et puis dans les deux cas aussi
évidemment il peut y avoir des
complications vous connaissez le fameux
le risque zéro n'existe pas si vous
voulez avoir des témoignages il y a mon
pote Maxime Muscat qui s'est fait opérer
il y a pas longtemps il a mis tout ça
sur insta je vous mets le lien dans la
description de la vidéo vous verrez il y
a pas mal de gens qui ont témoigné dans
les comes mais globalement les
principaux effets secondaires c'est les
yeux secs d'après les études qui ont été
menées il y aurait 23% de sécheresse
oculaire légère 3% de sécheresse modérée
et 3% de sécheresse sévère dans la
grande majorité des cas ça passe au bout
d'un à trois mois mais ça peut être
définitif donc faut le savoir avant des
infections ou des inflammations le grand
classique c'est le risque de toutes les
interventions chirurgicales là les
données de surveillance parlent de moins
d'1% des cas l'Agence française du
médicament et des produits de santé cite
aussi des troubles de la vision
post-opératoire qui sont rares mais je
vous mets quand même le communiqué dans
la description et puis il y a des effets
secondaires qui sont un petit peu plus
courants c'est l'apparition possible de
halo lumineux ou voir des éblouissements
et les difficultés à voir correctement
par luminosité réduite d'après les
données toujours ça régresse
généralement au bout de un à trois mois
après la cicatrisation mais voilà ça
peut être gênant donc faut le savoir
voilà tout ça c'est rare mais c'est
quand même des choses qu'il faut avoir
en tête avant de se faire opérer alors
pour le choix de la technique maintenant
et ben ça va dépendre de plusieurs
choses du type de trouble de la vue que
vous avez déjà la PKR c'est plutôt pour
les myopies faibles et pour la
stigmatisme le lastique ça marche pour
toutes les anomalies de la réfraction
donc myopie et astigmatisme mais aussi
ils permettronti et presbytie ensuite ce
qui va jouer c'est l'état de votre
cornée est-ce qu'elle est assez solide
pour supporter une découpe au laser déjà
et puis est-ce qu'elle est assez solide
pour supporter une opération tout court
il y a d'autres trucs à prendre en
compte aussi mais si vous voulez vous
faire opérer et bien vous verrez ça avec
le chirurgien pendant la consultation
préopératoire et puis il y a un autre
truc qui va jouer aussi on va pas se
mentir c'est votre budget
parce qu'il faut savoir que ça n'est pas
remboursé du tout par la Sécurité
sociale les mutuelles peuvent rembourser
une partie plus ou moins importante
selon le type de mutuelle que vous avez
mais de toute façon il vous restera
quelque chose à payer et comme vous avez
vu bon c'est pas exactement donner voilà
et puis si vous avez décidé de vous
faire opérer et que le chien chirurgien
a décidé que vous étiez opérable comment
ça se passe vous arrivez le jour de
l'opération et vous repartez juste après
juste en protégeant vos yeux et puis les
jours suivants vous mettez des gouttes
dans vos yeux pour éviter la sécheresse
oculaire pour favoriser la cicatrisation
pour éviter les infections etc mais bon
l'objectif de cette vidéo là aujourd'hui
c'était de vous expliquer comment ça
marche en théorie comment ça fonctionne
mais pour savoir comment ça se passe en
vrai dans la vraie vie en pratique sur
le terrain
vous commencez à me connaître maintenant
je vais aller tester ça moi-même bien
sûr ça tombe bien parce que je suis
presbyte justement et en plus c'est une
opération qui a quelques petites
particularités et puis bon je suis comme
qui dirait un petit peu habitué au laser
donc je vais me faire opérer et je
reviens très bientôt pour vous raconter
tout ça voilà DTC c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]